duro golpe para la libre empresa y el
Libre Mercado este lunes en Nicaragua
luego de la decisión del Ministerio de
gobernación de cancelar la personería
jurídica de 18 de los más importantes
gremios empresariales conformados en el
consejo superior de la empresa Privada
de Nicaragua se trata entonces de la
disolución de empresas relacionadas al
sector minero al sector del urbanismo y
de la construcción gremios relacionados
con los textiles con la pesca grandes
industrias que normalmente suelen
exportar sus productos con tasas
preferenciales hacia los Estados Unidos
y que representan un motor económico
para Nicaragua Pero que con la decisión
de hoy del gobierno de Ortega quedan
clausuradas y la razón del orteguismo de
cerrar estas empresas Es que le faltaron
a la transparencia faltaron a la ley por
no entregar los soportes de ventas los
ingresos y egresos de una manera
detallada al gobierno siendo que ellos
Siempre han sido fieles al sandinismo y
en materia de reacciones luz y valentí
empresaria actualmente exiliada y otrora
presidenta de la cámara nacional del
turismo dijo que Nicaragua con esta
decisión Está en camino hacia la
talibanización mientras que Félix
maradiaga férreo opositor de Ortega y
que fue uno de los desterrados
recientemente a Washington el pasado 9
de febrero dijo que esta decisión es la
cubanización del orteguismo